okay we're in detroit and we're doing
carrots this was adam's idea
[Music]
carrots
we filmed most of this episode at the
beginning of this year but we had to
pause production because of cover 19. so
we weren't able to finish the
episode like we normally do so you'll
notice some scenes are filmed here in
the highlander while we're still
practicing social distancing today on
worth it
we're going to be trying three different
carrot dishes
at three drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it
at its price adam found a very
delectable carrot steak that happens to
exist in detroit yeah a very exciting
carrot dish at that last location
and we're not just eating three carrots
it's going to be
three dishes where carrot is the primary
component
andrew the whole internet knows about
your love for carrot cakes
it's your birthday cake whatever you
want to call it
whatever you want to call it every day
you know my birthday is a birthday cake
that's the only
thing you ever call tell me about that
cake
yeah i love carrot cake i've had it
every birthday my whole life and so the
first place we're going to we're going
to have carrot cake we're going to a
place called
good cakes and bakes we're going to see
april the
chef and owner yeah we're going to get
one of those nice
slices
good cakes and bakes is an organic
bakery where everything is made in-house
from scratch
and we do vegan but our bakers are
mainly like southern type baked goods
since 2012 eight years ago people felt
like detroit was a food desert
and now there isn't too much of that you
can't find we're situated inside of five
neighborhoods bagley
sherwood forest green acres university
district and palmer woods
sherwood forest that is where marvin
gaye lived diana ross
lived there barry gordon all of the
motown stars but now
in this two and a half mile radius it is
the largest black owned building owners
as well as
businesses in the united states right
now so i've been baking since i was nine
years old but
i have an mba in corporate accounting
and i worked in accounting for 17 years
and then in 2009 i decided to go back to
school to get a degree at pastry arts
brienne one of our assistants is going
to walk you through and show you how we
make our
carrot cake our carrot cake is the best
carrot cake you ever taste i promise you
really
so what makes our carrot cake so unique
it is the different flavors you'll taste
orange you'll taste lemon you'll taste
vanilla you'll have the sweetness of the
carrots but what helps give us
the sweetness of it is how we allow the
raisins to
soak in hot water so by doing that you
don't have to add as much sugar to it by
adding the
flour in glass and creaming the oil and
the sugar that's how you get
fluffier tighter crumb opposed to a
dense cake
and then it's topped off with a sweet
and tart
cream cheese icing i guess i should warn
you that i've actually had carrot cake
every birthday
for pretty much my whole life my mom has
always made carrot cake i can't compete
with your mom but i promise you
this would be the second best carrot
cake you've ever had okay
looking forward to it yes
okay before we begin i want to just give
a huge shout out to the midwest
both adam and me are from ohio it feels
good to be back cozy feeling
cozies yes visually beautiful
you know it just has like that golden
hue to it looks very fluffy
it's nice and firm cheers
oh pretty good the texture is very kind
it has the kindness of the midwest in it
it's like soft
forgiving but also you know a little
stern
depending on whose carrot cake it is
sometimes it can skew a little
spice cake this one is fruitier it's so
bright in flavor it really like lifts my
mood up when i eat this
and the cream cheese icing has that like
tart dairy flavor
that strays away from just
straightforward sweetness
and i think is fantastic in cakes how
does this compare to your mom's carrot
cake i think this is a very good carrot
cake and if i was having a craving for
carrot cake i would be
very happy with this carrot cake are you
saying though that you can't beat your
mom's carrot cake i'm putting the spot
andrew we got april right there
listening
listen april this is an excellent carrot
cake thank you so it's like second to
your mom's right yeah yeah like this
i will say this is much better than my
mom's carrot cake my mom doesn't make
carrot
i can say cakes
quick time adam has the answer how much
did the world's
heaviest carrot weigh i mean carrots are
like a root and i've seen
overgrown roots of trees look pretty
massive so i'm gonna go with something
like
63 pounds i'm actually gonna go bigger
than that
i'm thinking the size of a regular adult
human
so i'm gonna go 135 pounds
22.44 pounds no
i was gonna guess lower but you threw me
off the trail andrew
so when i was born i came out just under
10 pounds
so it's like two of me that is yeah
that's a very big
carrot okay so our next carrot is
actually going to be a
carrot dog and it's a particular type of
dog called
a coney dog so i didn't know this about
detroit but coney island style hot dogs
are very common here
and that's a hot dog with chili onion
and mustard oh that sounds so good
i'm actually used to them with cheese on
top as well i love makoni dog's chili
cheese style
and so the next place we're going is a
place called noshpit where we're going
to see stefan
and karen and we're going to have their
lady fantastic coney carrot dog
are we gonna see up dog there what's up
dog
not much what's up with you
[Music]
we started out as a food truck doing
vegetarian vegan soups and sandwiches
here at the restaurant we are all vegan
all the time
so we're trying to do vegan food that is
more vegetable based rather than weird
starches and stuff
you know because this is a carrot
episode i want to check if either of you
have
a particular love or particular feelings
for the carrots
i was raised a lot by my grandmother
she was raised in the depression era
where the vegetables that we
stuck to were a lot of the root veggies
potatoes onions carrots the things that
kept
i have a particular love for root
vegetables because i find them more
sustainable
i noticed that coney island dogs are a
big thing here do you know why that is
greek folks moved from greece to
new york originally they invented slash
perfected the pony dog as they left in
new york
into the rest of the u.s they brought it
with them and i don't know why it took
root in detroit coney county restaurants
are
sort of the detroit version of a diner
so we're having a carrot dog but i
thought we should have a true detroit
coney dog first right dualies hot dog
chili onions mustard cheers yeah
the way the bun is steamed it's like a
hot dog
donut but instead of jelly it's chili it
is a sloppy joe
for hot dogs whoever thought that the
best condiment for meat would be more
meat was a genius
this coney dog is two dollars that's
wonderful that's home right there
so tell us about your coney carrot dog
so i wanted something that was hot
dog-ish
the shape is obviously the first idea
right but then
unlike a regular hot dog it does have
the sort of underlying sweetness to
it but it also has like a savory nature
i peel them and then i take
a cuber which is a little tool that has
a bunch of little blades in it basically
it just puts small holes into the flesh
of the carrot so the marinade can
penetrate a little better
i make a marinade and then i soak them
for
a minimum of three days we do a mixture
of
grilling and steaming at the same time
it's never going to be
hot dog texture it will have enough
bite to it that it's not mush in your
mouth
but yet it will be cooked enough that
it's not like eating a raw carrot
and it's a timing too because we also
have the chili it's
lentil-based onions garlic tomato paste
veg broth nowadays when people come in
and they'll ask for something unique
you know we have quite a few unique
things but this is something that's
familiar they know what the flavors
are a delightful
carrot dog so from this view it looks
like a hot dog from this view
you get the center of the carrot yeah
i'm very confused i want to eat it
though
okay okay me too dear steven
[Music]
i don't know why this wasn't more
obvious to me but it tastes better than
a hot dog
because i mean do you love hot dogs i
don't really love hot dogs
i'm all about the hot dog i mean let's
face it it's like the weakest
sausage
this is tastes like you know much more
than a hot dog
the carrot is also just the right
gunness for me
i don't like a carrot to get too soft i
want a little bit of crunch to remain
that crunch gives me that satisfying to
my soul
satisfaction yeah so they also have this
mac on cheese
one of the things that we're pretty well
known for locally is our mac and cheese
it's again completely vegan it's cashew
and potato is the base of the sauce
mac and cheese mac cheese yes
wait how does that taste so accurate
wait i'm confused yeah
now this is i mean this is a winner i'm
slightly lacking intolerance so
yeah there's no lactose here so go and
go crazy i'm gone i am going crazy right
now
one more thing to say about the care dog
i don't think i've ever seen so much
love and care put into
the preparation of a carrot before it is
very good and it's also very confusing
like my brain is just like jittering
right now
carefact carrot fact rabbits
do not naturally eat root vegetables
or fruits what whoa who
founded bugs bunny when will we stop
lying to children about everything their
diets are largely
hay slash grass as well as leafy greens
now that this fact has come into my life
i don't think i've ever seen a real life
rabbit
eat a carrot but now we gotta move on to
our
next restaurant our final carrot
this is actually the carrot dish that
motivated this trip to detroit
yes adam saw it and was like we should
do a carrot episode carrot alert
where are we going now stephen we're
going to lady of the house and we're
going to see
chef kate and her 20 carrot
steak that's right 20 and it is a carrot
turned into a steak
that is a loud bird that is a very loud
burp it's that one
that one yeah look at the bird
so lady of the house is kind of a new
american a little bit of an irish
hospitality feel
we like to say it's like throwing a
dinner party every night what we want to
drink what we want to eat and what we
want to serve we try to be no waste
which means we're using every part of
the animal every part of the vegetable
or fruit
and really kind of make the things taste
more like themselves
what a lot of people don't know is
michigan is the second most
agriculturally diverse state in the
country so the produce that comes out of
the state is really incredible
so before we get to the main event we've
got three
dishes just to give us a little more
taste of the menu so we have shrimp
butter
the lady ham trio and the half sour
cabbage
so shrimp butter's really interesting
the thought behind is what else can we
spread on toast
it's like beautiful shrimp that's almost
like emulsified in butter with aromatics
and then topped with butter
we've been making our own ham since we
opened right now we have our traditional
lady style parisian ham i love cabbage
and we've had
a version of a cabbage wedge on the menu
for a long time
this one gets a beautiful color on it
with not much work
and it already has like kind of a funk
and like umami flavor in it
let's do it so this is a shrimp butter
oh whoa cheers steven cheers
that's really good it reminds me of
seafoody cream cheese that you spread on
a bagel
yeah yeah all right next up what do we
got here lady ham trio
with parisian ham sassy molasses and the
lamb ham oh
i forgot the taste of meat for a while
oh because we've been eating carrots all
day yeah
i didn't know lamb can be ham but this
lamb is going ham
now we're easing back into vegetables
there's no mango in it but it tastes
like mango it's the miso it tastes like
60 of a reuben sandwich now onto the
main event
the inspiration for this dish actually
came from my time spent in copenhagen
i was working at a restaurant called
relay the way that they
cook vegetables is just incredible that
same philosophy would just like make the
carrot taste more like itself
this became a challenge for me of like
okay how can we make it worthy of our
restaurant
they're peeled and then shaved very
thinly
then we felt that basically taking the
water out breaking down the cell walls
so it's more malleable for us to
actually
line it up and roll it it actually gets
rolled into a rose
tied and then basically low and slow
care and patience basted with butter for
about 20 minutes we also serve the
carrot with hollandaise which is
traditionally served with steaks right
or eggs benedict but treating it like a
whole meal like an entree like a steak
would be
treated the perfect texture has a
beautiful crust
and then that fine line of melting
together from the butter
and salt and kind of the layers forming
together without being
you know mushy the attention to detail
and the care and the length of time it
takes to produce
makes it sort of
it's like a croissant of carrot i was
thinking crepe cake
yes should we taste the sauce first
let's do it
oh wow it's borderline cream cheesy
there are my layers i'm going to
scoop up a little sauce this really is
like fantasy food like they eat this in
the elven kingdoms in lord of the rings
because only they have the time to
meticulously slice
carrots cheers
[Music]
i knew what would happen to it i knew
going in what we were eating i've seen
pictures of it had no idea that was
going to happen
it was the same feeling of when you get
into a really good medium rare stick
and you feel the meat kind of like give
to your teeth yeah that's not carrot
the transformation here is absurd like
we're going from this
root to this it has the feelings of
unfamiliarity
and familiarity also think about carrots
are usually
the side dish or the afterthought yeah
and here
it's the centerpiece you know what it
actually tastes like carrot cake to me
there is
carrot flavor it's very buttery yeah
it's a sour
dairy flavor from the hollandaise and
then the pistachio is the nut that you
usually find in a carrot cake we're now
just eating a savory carrot cake
dessert cake yeah yeah you're right it's
wild this is one of the best thing i've
ever tasted
almost like perfectly cooked fish
not often do you get to eat foods you've
just never
eaten before andrew what was your
favorite thing in the episode
that was not a carrot mmm very
good question but i'm gonna go for the
easy answer
which was the coney dog at dooley's
that was delicious i gotta say the
midwest vibes
all right now it's time that we all been
waiting for what carrot
was the most worth it to you at a given
price point my winner is
lady of the house i love carrot cake i
respect all carrot cakes and
i'm gonna call that dish a carrot cake
and it was the most unique carrot cake
i've ever had my worth it winner it goes
to
good cakes and bakes and all of the
carrot cake
proprietors out there good kicks and
baked they did they did the right way
yeah good cakes and bakes it just made
me feel good being there
adam is your worth it winner the mac and
cheese uh nosh pet my carrot winner
good cakes and bakes okay well that does
it for this episode of worth it
look we got more stuff coming down the
pipeline yeah we're just getting started
next week quesadilla
[Music]
[Music]